in this way françoise's and my aunt made
a critical valuation between them in the
course of these morning sessions of the
earliest happenings of the day but
sometimes these happenings assume so
mysterious or so alarming an error that
my own felt she could not wait until it
was time for France woz to come upstairs
and that a formidable and quadruple peel
would resume through the house but madam
look David is not time for your pepsin
françoise's would begin are you feeling
faint no thank you for us was my aunt
Roberta that is that is just say yes for
you know well but there is very seldom a
time when I don't feel faint one day I
shall pass away like Madonna or so
before I know where I am but that is not
why I ring would you believe that i have
just seen as plainly as I see you Madame
goo peel with a little girl I didn't
know it all Ron and get a penny worth of
salt from Camus it's not often that town
or can't tell you what person is but
that must be miss Jo cabanas daughter
françoise's would say preferring to
stick to an immediate suit explanation
since she had been perhaps twice already
into [ __ ] that morning mr. Pappas
daughter oh that's a likely story my
poor Francois do you think I should not
have recognized mr. bluebells daughter
but I don't mean the big one madam dad I
mean the little girl the one goes to
school issue ye I seem to have seen her
once already this morning oh if that's
what it is my aunt would say she must
have come over for the holidays oh yes
that's it no need to ask she would have
come over for the holidays but then we
shall soon see Madame Sassenach come
along and rain her sisters doorbell for
her luncheon that will be it I saw the
boy from Gallup pants go by with a chart
you will see that the tart was for
Madame Pele once Madame Kabir has gone
into the house madam octa you won't be
long inseam although going into their
lunch in there for it's not so early as
it was would be the answer
false was who was an just retired
retired downstairs to look after our own
meal was not sorry to leave my aunt with
the prospect of such a distraction oh
not before midday I on would reply in a
tone of resignation darking an uneasy
glance at the clock but stealthily so as
not to let be seen that she who had
renounced all earthly joys you have
found a keen satisfaction in learning
that Madonna appeal was expecting
company to luncheon though alas she must
wait a little more than a mat power
still before enjoying the spectacle and
it will come in the middle of mine
action she would murmured to herself her
luncheon was such a distraction in
itself that she did not like any other
to come at the same time at least you
will not forget to give me my green eggs
on one of the flat plates these were the
only plates which had pictures on them
and my aunt used to amuse herself at
every meal by reading the description on
whichever might have been sent up to her
she would put on her spectacles and
spell out Ali Baba and the Forty Thieves
Aladdin or the wonderful down and smile
and say good indeed I may as well go
across to Cameroon françoise's would
hazard seeing that my aunt no longer had
any intention of sending her there no no
it's not worthwhile now it's certain to
be the Pope anchor my office was I am
sorry too I made you come upstairs for
nothing but it was not for nothing as my
aunt well knew that she had rung for
cross was since I comprehend a person
who won to know it all was as incredible
a being as any mythological deity and it
was apt to be forgotten that after each
occasion on which they had appeared in
the Buddhist a spree or in square one of
those bewildering phenomena careful and
exhaustive researches had invariably
reduced the fab
monster but the proportions of a person
who won you know either personally or in
the abstract in his or her civil status
as being more or less closely related to
some family in home ray it would turn
out to be madam so tell Sonny discharged
from the army or the update paired Rose
nice come home from her convent or the
curious brother a tax collector at
chateau de who had just retired on a
pension or had come over to come brave
for the holidays I'm first noticing them
you had been impressed by the thought
that there might be incorporate people
who didn't know at all simply because
you had failed to recognize or identify
them at once and yet beforehand long
beforehand Madame so Tom and the Cure a
had given warning that they expected
they're strangers in the evening when I
came in and went upstairs to tell my
aunt the incidence of our walk if I was
rash enough to say to her that we had
passed near the polio a man who my
grandfather didn't know grandfather
didn't know at all she would exclaim
that's a likely story nonetheless she
would be a little disturbed by the news
she would wish to have the details
correctly and so my grandfather would be
summoned who could it have been did you
Pastor the pool view on a man who didn't
know at all of course course I did my
grandfather would answer it was a
prospere but on we Bluffs Gardner's
brother oh well my aunt would say calm
again but slightly flushed ill and the
boy told me you had passed a man who
didn't know at all after which I would
be more warrant to be more careful of
what I said and not to upset my aunt my
soap thoughtless remarks everyone was so
well known in cold rain animals as well
as people that if my aunt had happened
to see a dog go by we
she didn't know at all she would think
about it incessantly devoted to the
solution of the incomprehensible problem
all her inductive talent and her leisure
hours that will be met on Sasha Roiz dog
françoise's would suggest without any
real conviction but in the hope of peace
and so that my aunt should not split her
head as if i did not know madam
sassafras dog for my aunt's critical
mind would not so easily admit any fresh
past ah but that will be the new dog
Madame galin panel has brought her from
these yo that's what it is it seems it's
a most engaging animal false woz would
go on having got the story from Teodor
as clever as a Christian always a good
temper always friendly always everything
that's nice it's not often you see an
animal so well behaved at that age but
don't have it's high time I left you I
can't afford to stay here amusing myself
look it's nearly ten o'clock and my fire
not I did yet and I've still got to
dress the asparagus what Frost was more
asparagus it's a regular disease of
asparagus or what up this year when you
will make operation sick of it no no
Adamek Tov they'd like it well enough
they'll be coming back from church sooo
hungry as hunters and they won't eat it
up at the back of their spoons you'll
see church like they must be there now
you'd better not lose any time go and
like after your lunch